[Music]
[Music]
we made tap handles for blood Weiser
Goose Island Miller Lite
you know I think this is a first with an
actual snow globe on tap handle yeehaw
Pale Ale I like this one because it's
just a big awesome looking tap any
steagle Prescott and central waters to
name a few a mark Steinhardt general
manager of ajs tap hands I definitely
would try that beer so a guy walks into
a bar and the first thing he does if
it's me I look what's on tap certainly
the unique fat pebbles piqued your
interest and might push you to try that
beer I like this tap handle because I'm
a little breaker we're located in random
Lake Wisconsin which is about 45 minutes
north of Milwaukee
even though Wisconsin is a rural state
we produced tap handles for the mega
breweries on down to the smallest micro
group we believe we're the largest
domestic producer in town
yes we ship out approximately a half a
million cat pendants issue we can
produce the tap metal from start to
finish this is a very detailed tap
handle and I would guess takes about an
hour to hand paint all the detail on it
companies do try to have the most
eye-catching most unique tap handle in
the bar than it is a cross between art
and manufacturing we always say our cap
handle will sell your first beer and
your beer will sell the rest in the cold
white north of Minnesota there's a place
that will get you warm after a long day
on the ice you can do some fishing for
have a tasty beverage
and it's something of a dream for Josie
I've always wanted to own a neighborhood
bar and we finally do mine's just
sitting on a frozen lake ice fishing is
a way of life around here for people it
gets so cold below zero temps quite
often which allows us to dry then put
houses out and drill holes in the lake
and fish when it gets cold enough in the
early winter
Josie's husband goes out and tests the
ice to make sure it's thick enough
[Music]
if it is they can put the bar together
and then the ISIL can open the ice here
is so thick that this bar sits on top of
it to come to our bar on the lake you
just drive your car out on the ice and
park we don't have a parking lot you
just park wherever you want walk in and
have a beer
people like to fish and drink beer and
from our bar here you can do that all at
the same time the local favorite drink
here is called the minnow shot people
will actually take a live middle which
is fishing bait and put it into their
shop and drink it as delicious is that
seafood beverage sounds people come just
because the fact that the bar exists is
pretty amazing
people's reactions to this bar are from
crazy - they don't understand it that's
the coolest thing ever
they come from all over the world to see
it it's very seasonal we're only open 20
days if you're ever near like light a
drive out on the ice Park come into the
bar and grab a pole
[Music]
pubs there's thousands of them but this
story is about just four and what makes
them so special they're old this guy
thinks his pub is oldest and fair bit
older our rights no way I guess we
should look into this in that case
welcome to the search for the oldest pub
in the world take the floor landlord
once welcome to the old trip dilution
the oldest pub in England so the
landlord boards go back to 1760 hoping
other caves go back to 1070 when the
first castle was built up here here is
the wooden galleon don't touch it out
everyone who's cleaned it it's come to a
mysterious end who knows if for the
oldest pub in the world where we shall
serve the best part of the world
[Music]
learn not to you're up welcome to the
old ferryboat the oldest pub in England
and possibly the world is until the last
coaster no no no it is right this pub
has been dated back to 1050 ad but
legend has it it's 500 years older so
it's pretty old pretty damn old we don't
have any silly ships here but we do have
a ghost this pub was built on the grave
of a young girl for Juliet's but one
thing's for sure we do serve the best
point let's hear it landlord three
welcome to your man inside it's so old
we don't even know exactly how old it is
the records go back to twelve fifty one
but the design of our cellar is before
the turn of the century so you don't
know it's definitely older than the
others though right
one ghost we've got way more than that
we've got 53 and one in particular is
way better than theirs
in 1651 James Stanley the seventh Earl
of Derby was executed right here during
the English Civil War ed oldest pub in
the world we think so but one thing's
for sure we pull the best pint in the
world wait I haven't introduced up you
there there are many who claim to be the
oldest but we are fully researched and
dated as the oldest come on in you're
very welcome chance the Barretts elf is
actually older to the town itself almost
all the owners are on record even back
to the original owner Lewin himself in
900 and he guided people across the old
fort just here over here in the walls is
a letter answered from the Guinness Book
of World Records have we found it you
have found it and you're very welcome to
Shaun's every bearers got to clear the
best beer doors but we can certainly
plan with the best whiskey in the world
this has gotta be the best excuse for a
pub crawl ever
jail
[Music]
[Music]
the body man is our speciality well for
centuries and self in fairly
the unusual is very payment in a this
guy would get dressed up once a year the
China they all the bad luck together
maybe hopefully give him a good harvest
so you touched off with your luck or you
can't eat one of these Reapers and I'll
give you good luck I'm Andrew Taylor and
then the bunny man I'm so pleased here
[Music]
to reflect obviously all over a thousand
pairs we take the value we dry them off
yeah well out of my face
and they actually saw the baklava
curtisha and I'm a t-shirt to my toes
and also salt and then they just stack
the verse on me pretty much one by one
from head to toe
[Music]
they cut yeah we do this escape yeah you
don't really feel comfortable you sit
down you're uncomfortable you're walking
you're uncomfortable you sort of never
really that comfortable plasma to help
first don't learn and you come up
that they hold the pose and they they
belong selfies rate but also just make
sure I'm okay because I can't see down
exactly stay ahead
[Music]
what on the horse of beans very as much
of that as I can enter streaks war
people they come out with drums or
basket and the job take a sip of whiskey
stops all of it also cleans ready and
then I had the high street going to all
the pubs restaurants for mr. burski I
must warn though 810 male overall I
would see
a clean slate especially we get very
excited on the day of money man you
normal as body man's day they all really
enjoyed all kind of the very parent of
this and asked the traditional not many
people can say they've been the body man
there's only a few that I know all the
happy the body man's of food sales those
great days be a paradox or tear it up in
the body man know for five years is a
very big honor he informs of Prince fada
for my wife may have seen the body man
cells and those seven eight year old
that do pass on the software the person
takes over just carries on as fantastic
leadership that's only offer because as
such a unique traditional year in the
never one that disappear and other at
all fake animal senator always be a
polymath away from the body
[Music]
our founding fathers were booze hounds
so much so that Benjamin Franklin
published a dictionary of 228 words that
all describe one thing being blind drunk
in the 13 colonies we love to drink
colonial Americans were perpetually
bombed
especially since water wasn't always
clean and accessible many of our
nation's most respected men could be
found with a glass or two in hand in
fact Thomas Jefferson drafted the
Declaration of Independence while drunk
on Madeira George Washington racked up
an epic bar tab of over 160 bottles for
just fifty four delegates zone me and
John Adams went on a seven-week binge
drinking six hours a night with younger
congressmen keep drinking so Franklin
took a stab at his peers and published
the terms he overheard at local pubs in
the drinkers dictionary here's what they
said I've got corns in my head oh go eat
a pudding bag Thomas you're one to talk
Washington you're as dizzy as a goose
I'm shambled my goodness Hamilton you've
got a brass eye today well the king was
his cousin clearly gentlemen you're all
wasted
[Music]
you
[Music]